sorpresa che cosa pietrifico sto
T Aspetta ce la faccio ce la
[Musica]
faccio
ma Vitale l'ho trovato 3 2 1 via vieni
Marino Vieni vieni
vieni piccolo salta
petrificus chi inizia il nascondino
entreremo qua in questo cappetto di
calcio chi riesce a fare gol inizierà
per primo io sono una grandissima
schiappa calcio e non capisco neanche le
regole non capisco niente Quindi anch'io
non vi preoccupate non so giocare a
calcio Ok io faccio da portiere adesso 3
2 1
via l'ai presa Brava Ora provo io a
tirare anche se sto già che non ci
riuscirò
vediamo piano non si tira in faccia vale
lo stesso se colpisco il portiere No non
vale lo stesso Opa riproviamo
[Musica]
allora
nmo tirare
addosso AV Vito Vitale quindi inizierà
Vitale a nascondersi bene mentre Vitale
si nasconde Io mi metto dentro la
casetta a contare dove si
nasconderà Eccolo là dietro non posso
spiare ora 2 3 4 5 6 tempo scaduto m
andiamo subito a cercare Vitale State
bene attenti anche voi se lo vedete
prima di me scrivetelo nei
commenti forse vicino allo scivolo
vediamo non c'è nessuno
qua
Beh allora provo ad entrare dentro al
parco giochi e vediamo se riusciamo a
trovarlo andiamo
m non so se salire da qua oppure salire
da là forse dovrei salire
qua
ma Vitale l'ho trovato Ora non mi resta
che andare a prenderlo Ma cosa gli è
venuto in mente a nascondersi lì nella
parte trasparente lo vedo benissimo lì
Tanto ora arrivo a prenderti Vediamo se
riuscirà a scappare Ah ok si sale da qua
andiamo ok Sto salendo su per
raggiungere Vitale lui non è ancora
scappato Non capisco perché è inutile
che continui a nasconderti ti ho visto
sei lassù nel tubo vedo anche l'ombra
nel tubo Guardate Eccolo lì lo vedete si
sta spostando sta scappando di
là devo andare di là a prenderlo Wow Qua
c'è un ponticello andiamo
Oplà Tanto ora ti prendo non riuscirai a
scappare No non mi prenderai invece
vedremo Ehi tu puoi riuscire a vincere
se riesci a tornare nella casetta prima
che io ti prenda Ah nella casetta va
bene Ci sto tanto ora ti prendo oh no oh
no ma sei così vicina
Aiuto non puoi scappare ormai so dove
che Stai faccendo
laggiù
Oh no ha trovato un passaggio sta
passando da quella parte devo
raggiungerlo da dove passo da qua o da
lì m provo a passare da questo ponte non
pensare di sfuggirmi
ormai ti sto raggiungendo ok Oh no è già
laggiù presto sbrighiamoci Eccolo Questo
era Il nascondiglio di Vitale Ferma
ferma lo scappare sono avanti Ciao
ferma Ehi non mi prenderai fermo te Te
ormai ti ho trovato no fermo fermo Ciao
io
scappo io scappo
arrivato Oh devo scappare devo scappare
preso preso Prendi prendi questo anche
questo è anche questo ti ho preso Ti ho
anche trovato ho trovato il tuo
nascondiglio perché il tuo nascondiglio
non era proprio
visto cheo da fuori ho vinto il primo
round Toca nascondermi Vai vai a contare
non sbirciare eh 2 3 vai dentro la
casetta è troppo piccola Vitale non ci
sta Ho un'idea per questo nascondiglio
invece di nascondermi in questa sala di
Dada party andrò nell'altra sala dove
stai
andando più difficile che Vitale mi
trovi nell'altra sala
SH dov'era Ah di qua
venite
sbrighiamoci Ecco qua l'altra sala dove
mi potrei nascondere Qua c'è un altro
campetto di calcio Qua c'è un altro
parco giochi Guardate quanti tubili mi
sa che mi nascondo qua vediamo da dove
si entra Ah si entra da qua andiamo Ecco
qua secondo me Vitale non mi troverà qua
Ma saliamo fin sopra nel tubo
colorato Oh no Vitale è già arrivato
devo sbrigarmi
è già qua nella seconda
sala ti
troverò devo nascondermi in quella parte
del tubo no lì al
centro
Non so se riesco a raggiungerla lui è
proprio lì Stè entrato sta entrando qua
lo
vedete
aiuto è rimasto
incastrato Come si fa a passare da qui
aiuto Vitale è troppo grande non
riuscivo a passare da lì meglio che mi
sbrigo devo andare dentro al
tubo Guardate che bello
coloratissimo Oh no sta arrivando Vale
spiamo
[Musica]
aiuto
Beh penso di essere nascosta bene qua
Guardate sento dei rumori strani ma
dov'è
lui ti ho
trovata scappiamo da Vitale
aspettami Cè passare
lì
stretto addio ciao ciao io scappo che
succede Sei caduta di nuovo Sì aspetta
aspetta
aspetta ciao Ciao Anche se hai trovato
il mio nascondiglio non sei riuscito a
prendermi ora scendo da questo
scivolo Eccola giù
[Applauso]
Vitale sei troppo lento pensav di averla
fatta
Franca Oh no devo passare da qua dove
stai andando dove stai scappando aiuto
Come si passa da qua Beh almeno Vitale
rimarrà incastrato qua forse no fatti
prendere Ah aspetta ti prendo ti prendo
adesso Ecco qua lucita ma vediamo prima
se Vitale riesce a superare questa parte
oh no oh no qua mi sono incastrato prima
Oh aspetta
Qua
Aiuto Aiuto Sono rimasto appeso Oh no
Poverino aiutiamolo aiut invece no era
Ah ti ho presa sono riuscita a prenderti
ho vinto per il secondo round Vitale ha
trovato il mio nascondiglio e anche è
riuscito a prendermi eravamo proprio
nascosti qua nel tubo era nascosta qua
passiamo ora al terzo round terzo round
tocca a me
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 veloce veloce
veloce Ci nascondiamo
qui Ciao zucca Eh oh no Sembri Mister
potato o una zucca Non lo so sono qui
nel castello Magari lei non se ne
accorge do sei m Secondo me sei nascosto
qua
vediamo
ho scelto davvero un bel nascondiglio
non riesci a
trovarmi dove
sei È proprio lì in fondo non mi troverà
mai
qui forse nell'altra
sala Sì sì forse proprio nell'altra sala
Vai a controllare mentre io resto qui ho
sentito una voce prov venire da qua oh
no
Eh forse qua
dentro oh oh oh
oh no no sto arrivando proprio qui
aiuto Eccoti Ti ho trov scappare devo
scappare becc di no questo non si stacca
via via via via via via via via via
scivola scivola scivolo scappiamo
scappiamo scappiamo fermo Ehi
aspetta Aiuto aiuto Ehi stai cadendo sto
Aiuto ho toccato i tuoi piedi ti ho
preso perché ho toccato i tuoi piedi
puzzolenti quindi ho VTO io ma io sono
caduto dalle scale per te aiuto ultimo
round Questo è il round decisivo devo
nascondermi io quindi voi rimanete con
Vitale Cont Sì sì andiamo a contare 1 du
Dove stai andando nella casetta non pui
guardare Ok Ok andiamo nella casetta
Allora allora andiamo Vai nella casetta
e inizia a contare da lì ok Vado nella
Cetta e inizio a contare da qui Ok vado
Basta
Ahia 2 3 4 5 6 Che noia però contare Dai
sbrigati ti sei nascosta 14 116 128 132
137 28 penso proprio che si sia nascosta
Allora andiamo subito a controllare dove
si sarà nascosta
vediamo allora qui non credo che si sarà
nascosta perché mi sono nascosto prima
io qua
m qui No probabilmente no perché è
troppo piccolo secondo me si è nascosta
qui io penso che sia questo il posto
dove si è nascosta Anita quindi venite
con me Andiamo a
trovarla Ah bravo magari si è nascosta
qui nella zona
scivolo vediamo oppure
oppure no forse sopra Anita Dove
sei Eh ma si è nascosta proprio
bene proviamo a fare lo zoom e cercare
di trovarla qui da qualche parte dove
sarà
Ciao Hai visto Anita dove Sii
nascosta è un osso duro non vuole
parlare Ok proviamo a cercarla
qui Beh che c'hai da guardare tu hai
visto dove si è nascosta Anita per
caso
Ehi ma si è mosso ti sei
mosso sei un po' sospetto tu eh
cos'era quel
rumore no non c'è
lì nemmeno Ehi ma non riesco a capire
dov'è che si è nascosta eppure ho
sentito un rumore qui
prima Ma questo era un rumore che
proveniva proprio da lì ma qui ci sono
solo delle
palline ma eh quelle palline si sono
mosse secondo me c'è qualcosa di
sospetto là sotto andiamo a vedere e chi
se la ricorda la strada per uscire da
qui adesso Oh
no sono riuscito ad uscire non ci credo
Allora andiamo a controllare perché
c'erano Quei movimenti là m qui sembra
tutto normale Sono però Quasi sicuro di
aver visto qualcosa muoversi
qui ho capito forse Anita si è nascosta
proprio qui adesso le faccio un bello
scherzetto No non era
qui e se provo a spostare tutte le
palline magari R uscirà fuori prima o
poi
troviamo No neanche qui c'è in
quell'angolo andiamo
Cata No non ci
sei No non c'è neanche qui Uffa però
dove
sarà mi riposo un po'
[Musica]
qui sorpresa che cosa C fa ti Preto ti
PR aiut scappiamo scappiamo scappi ti
prendo non mi hai trovata Prova a
prendermi se ci riesci Certo che ti
prendo Non ci credo er non mi hai
trovata
er ti hoa mi hai presa Ma non mi hai
trovata pensavi di riuscire a scappare
Ehi aspetta un momento tu quanti round
hai
vinto Chi ha vinto questa partita forse
l'hai vinta tu scrivete nei commenti Chi
ha vinto ma soprattutto volete una
rivincita Ok inizio io a nascondere i
regali di Vitale Ehi tu devi andare
Laggiù nella casetta e nasconderti e non
guardare dove nascondo i regali
Altrimenti se guardi dove nascondo i
regali staresti barando Ecco qua i
regali di Vitale iniziamo a
nascondere questo ho un'idea nascondiamo
il primo
regalo sotto alle palline lo troverà mai
lì
primo regalo nascosto Passiamo al
secondo secondo regalo Guardate un po' è
piccolo piccolo sembra un cioccolatino
qua
sopra terzo
regalo dove nascondiamo questo ma voi
non sapete una cosa tra i regali di
Vitale che ho preparato Ci sono vari
scherzetti ma scoprirete una volta che
Vitale aprirà i vari regali
sbrighiamoci Guardate Siamo in cima al
parco giochi Siamo proprio in alto ho
deciso di nascondere questo regalo
proprio qua Ecco
fatto se ne accorgerà Vitale da laggiù
che il regalo è qua vedremo ultimi due
regali per Vitale ho deciso di
nasconderne uno qua vicino all scivolo
Ecco fatto e questo gigante Dove posso
nasconderlo Ho un'idea facciamolo
scivolare dallo scivolo così vitale per
prenderlo Dovrà per forza scivolare
quaggiù vediamo 3 2 1 ciao
ciao ha fatto proprio un bel volo Ciao
ciao tocca a me adesso andiamo a
nascondere i regali di Anita Wow
Wow Lo mettiamo
qui così da non farlo più vedere primo
regalo nascosto Ecco qui un altro regalo
per Anita ma questa volta lo nasconderò
sopra
aiuto ok là in fondo è dove abbiamo
nascosto il primo regalo dobbiamo stare
attenti superare tutti questi ostacoli
Ma io sono Vitale e partirò a
Bobba passato visto che è rosa magari si
mimetizza bene m Credo di sì andiamo io
lo nasconderei qui nell'angolino così
non lo vede e non la trova Wow siamo
nell'altra sala e qui nasconderò gli
altri regali di Anita venite con
me nasconderò questo qui così non sarà
facile trovarlo vedete è proprio qua
sotto sopra lo cercherà tantissimo prima
di trovarlo andiamo a nascondere questo
adesso geniale l'idea di nasconderlo lì
non lo troverà mai ci impiegherà tanto
tempo e questo darà più tempo a me per
cercare i regali che ha nascosto lei oh
sarò in vantaggio già dall'inizio Eh
buongiorno Oh no vi ricordate questi
l'altra volta sono rimasto incastrato
qui e poi son caduto per andare al piano
di sopra dobbiamo attraversare
quest'altro quadrato di palline Uh
proverò a nascondere il regalo di Anita
proprio qua dietro così per trovare il
regalo dovrà attraversare tutto questo
tubo è super mitizzato non se ne
accorgerà mai Anita che è qui ok tutti i
regali sono stati nascosti Chi riesce a
trovare aprire tutti i regali potrà poi
andare a cerca del regalo d'oro pronti 3
2 1
vi da dove iniziamo provo a entrare qua
Vitale è già sparito sta già cercando i
regali devo sbrigarmi c'è nessuno
qua non vedo nessun regalo qua Mannaggia
controlliamo meglio c'è
nessuno
regali dove siete regali Speravo ci
fosse qualcosa qua sotto ma non c'è
niente proviamo a entrare nell'altra
area
Ehi c'è nessuno sto parlando ai regali
come se potessero rispondermi
piscina di
palline
guardate C'è qualcosa
qua Sì ho trovato il mio primo regalo
apriamo subito il regalo vediamo Che
cos'è Secondo
voi sono qui Ma che ci fai lì ti devi
buttare Sì sono pronto a buttarmi perché
ho trovato un regalo laggiù no l'hai già
trovato Vitale ha già trovato uno dei
regali e forse Troverà anche altro
perché l'ho nascosto lì vicino vi
ricordate sbrighiamoci apriamo il nostro
primo regalo che cosa
sarà Che cos'è E alla fine del video
scrivete nei commenti Qual è stato il
vostro regalo preferito per i regali
rosa e il vostro regalo preferito per i
regali blu di
Vitale una bacchetta Wow È bellissima
Guardate dovrebbe essere la bacchetta di
Hermione potrò trasformare Vitale in un
animagus adesso un rospa Ehi Vitale Eh
petrificus
totalus oh no Hai già trovato il primo
regalo l'hai pure spacchettato Sì sono
in vantaggio anche se tu l'hai trovato
lì c'è un regalo Guarda sto arrivato a
prenderlo No l'hai schiacciato
Ops
ma non sembra sia rotto pronti scopriamo
che
cos'è Oh è
gigante cosa sarà un panino
gigante Finalmente si mangia Vitale
Pensa Davvero che quello sia un vero
panino gigante c'ho una fame che non ti
dico Guarda E vabbè meglio che mi sbrigo
altrimenti Vitale sarà in vantaggio
Foresto andiamo io intanto mi fermo a
mangiare questo panino Va bene vai vai
vai sìì va benissimo
Ciao
Eh è
sottovuoto
Ehi
ma aspetta un attimo
Ehi Parino Sott
vuoto
Met di stoffa è un cuscino non si mangia
questo No speriamo che gli altri regali
siano cibo vero Però dai andiamo a
cercarle Aspettate a vedere i prossimi
regali che G ho fatto Ci rimarrà male
Carissimo devo riuscire a trovare tutti
i regali Prima di Vitale aprire il
regalo d'oro cosa ci sarà Secondo voi
nel regalo d'oro Secondo me potrebbe
esserci un tablet un cellulare è molto
piatto molita Eh ti volevo ringraziare
della bella baguette che mi hai dato eh
è finta Eh che cosa ti aspettavi un vero
panino gigante Sì sarebbe stato
fantastico e me lo sarei mangiato tutto
sai che fame che c'ho Me Ne mangerei due
di
queste mi dispiace per te e gli altri
regali non ne hai trovato nessuno No
solo uno al momento bene meglio così
così sono in vantaggio Ciao ciao vediamo
se c'è qualcosa Qua attraversiamo questo
corridoio
m c'è nessuno Dov'è l'altro regalo qua
non c'è niente vediamo dentro questa Ma
come ho faccio a non accorger me era
proprio lì
Evviva secondo regalo trovato pesa
tantissimo vediamo Che cos'è Chissà se
Vitale ha trovato il secondo regalo o se
sono io in vantaggio apriamolo vediamo
Che
[Musica]
cos'è un libro sapete che io adoro i
libri adoro leggere Il giardino segreto
che carino ma ora è meglio che mi sbrigo
non so se Vitale ha già trovato il
secondo regalo forse anche il terzo
cerchiamo gli altri sbrighiamoci vediamo
se c'è qualcosa nascosto qua in questo
corridoio controllate bene anche voi se
vedete qualche regalo
qua non c'è niente qua Ehi Vediamo se da
qua riesco a vedere Vitale Ehi ma che
stai facendo arrampicando là sopra eh Mi
stavo arrampicando per arrivare a
controllare lassù Magari ha nascosto
qualche regalo lassù non te lo dico non
posso dirti dove ho nascosto i
regali Ne ho trovato uno Guardate è
proprio lì lo vedete andiamo subito a
prenderlo proprio là sopra Anita non sa
che in realtà ho trovato anche un altro
regalo solo che non ho fatto in tempo a
prenderlo
prima Ah siete qua Guardate vedete lì
c'è un altro regalo eh Ma dov'è il
regalo doveva essere lì o forse forse
era qui era arancione Infatti non giallo
Vediamo se è di
qua oh no qui non si vede
niente piano
piano in equilibrio Eccolo è proprio lì
è qualcosa di Rotondo profuma anche
molto bene che cosa sarà mai saranno dei
biscotti sembra il contenitore dei
biscotti Guardate sembra un
contenitore cibo è cibo è cibo che bello
cibo S Finalmente si mangia cibo cibo
[Musica]
C Salad Ok Sembra un'insalata calzini di
insalata cosa ma c'è anche la forchetta
no c'è la forchetta è quella che
sembrava insalata e pomodori sono dei
calzini a forma di insalata con la
cipolla il pomodoro e le olive ma quindi
non si mangiano tutto questo parlare di
insalata mi sta facendo venire una fame
ho cambiato area del dat party chissà
cosa starà facendo Vitale adesso avrà
già trovato i regali scherzo che gli ho
fatto e via il pieno di sotto Eccolo qua
altro regalo apriamo apriamo togliamo il
fiocchetto questo Sembra davvero cibo
questo è cibo per davvero questa volta
questa volta sono delle patatine apriamo
apriamo apriamo le
patatine
[Musica]
calzini calzini di nuovo sono sempre
calzini Non ci posso credere calzini di
patatine proviamo ad entrare are qua
dentro vediamo se c'è qualche regalo
nascosto qua Ehi c'è qualche regalo qua
Wow questa piscinetta di palline è
ancora più grande vediamo se c'è
qualcosa
qua sbaglio c'è qualcosa
lì un regalo l'ho trovato riesco a
prenderlo da qua senza dover salire
nello scivolo Ehi ce l'ho fatta ho
trovato l'altro regalo senza dover
salire sopra apriamolo subito e vediamo
com'è se Vitale Ora avrà già trovato
tutti i suoi regali scherzetti Che cos'è
un peluche è un peluche è un Pokémon
Espeon adoro Espeon è super carino Ora
sbrighiamoci dobbiamo trovare l'ultimo
regalo andiamo Ah ragazzi ho cercato
dappertutto ma non riesco a trovare
l'ultimo regalo l'unico punto in cui non
sono salita è qua sopra questo scivolo
Si vede che non c'è nessun regalo qua eh
Vabbè proviamo a salire lo stesso mi
piacciono le mie calze di Harry Potter
vedete non c'è niente
uffa Ma dove l'avrà nascosto non c'è
proprio niente qua Wow da qua sopra
riesco a vedere tutta la sala che bello
m Forse da qua riuscirò a trovare il
regalo
vediamo Uffa non trovo
niente no non ci credo lo aveva nascosto
qua nel tetto è stato difficilissimo da
trovare ma come gli è venuto in mente di
nasconderlo sul tetto apriamolo subito e
poi possiamo partire subito alla ricerca
del regalo d'oro sembra che Vitale non
l'abbia già trovato m che cosa
sarà un
cerchietto sapete che io adoro i
cerchietti che car ino vediamo come mi
sta Tad come vi sta vi piace ma ora non
perdiamo altro tempo andiamo subito alla
ricerca del regalo d'oro Ehi questi me
li ricordo l'altra volta mi sono
sfracellato un sacco di volte e pensavo
fossero gelati in realtà Ma no sono
degli spuntoni che cosa c'è là sopra
Cos'è quello non ci posso credere questa
sì che è un cioccolatino che brava Nida
mi conosce troppo bene un cioccolatino
adesso me lo mangio subito finalmente
cioccolato Eccolo eccolo è cioccolato
per davvero questa volta è davvero
qualcosa da mangiare Guardate cioccolata
è di gomma No anche questo non è
cioccolata è una pennetta USB fatta a
forma di cioccolata Oh C'è ancora un
altro regalo da andare a cercare andiamo
e speriamo che questa volta sia qualcosa
da mangiare per davvero Vitale A che
punto sei con la tua caccia ai regali
perché io ho trovato tutti i miei regali
dove sei Sono
qui
Qualcosa mi dice che hai trovato i
regali cibo finto sto piangendo su
questa barretta di cioccolato
finta pensavo fosse del cioccolato vero
invece no ma vogliamo parlare di tutti
gli altri regali eh tipo le patatine
fritte calze o l'insalata calze Eh ti
sembrano dei regali da fare a uno
affamato come me ma è proprio per questo
che le ho fatti è super divertente ti
manca ancora un regalo da trovare allora
devo sbrigarmi devo cercare il regalo
d'oro così posso vincere io Ah sì è vero
mi manca ancora un altro regalo meglio
che mi sbrigo via via via via via Wow
Ahia
ahia Eccolo ho trovato l'altro regalo
l'ultimo questo deve essere
assolutamente cibo Speriamo speriamo
proprio non vedo l'ora questo è cibo
questo è cibo Ne sono sicuro è cibo è
cibo cibo Sì è cibo è cibo questo si
vede dalla confezione che è cibo è sushi
è sushi Che bello è sushi vegetariano
apriamo Oh Troppo carino ma Ehi qui
manca la salsa di soia c'è anche il
Wasabi e lo zenzero Ma come si mangia
eh Non mi dire che anche questa è
una calza è una calza non ci credo non è
possibile non è possibile non mi dire
che anche
questa Anche questa è una calza niente
cibo Anita
Anita dove sei Mi ha ingannato anche
questa volta dove potrebbe essere il
regalo d'oro non abbiamo cercato qua in
quest'area Non può essere dentro la
casetta perché Vitale prima si
nascondeva dentro all casetta e non
c'era niente Anita vogliamo parlare del
Sushi calzino l'hai già trovato Sì E che
vuol dire che adesso Cercherò anch'io il
regalo
d'oro tu che cosa hai visto qui Hai
trovato qualcosa Eh senti io cerco qua e
tu cerca di là ok se tu cerchi di qua e
lo trovi è tuo se io cerco di là e lo
trovo è mio Sì ok vado Ah meno male è
andato cerchiamo
qua sono stanca io mi riposo un
pochettino Speriamo che lo trovi Vitale
Ehi Che stai facendo Stai dormendo di
già no mi stavo solo rotando un momento
tu l'hai trovato No io non ho trovato
niente Tu neanch'io sentio Ora voglio
riposarmi un po' ok cercalo tu Ciao No
io ho cercato dappertutto non l'ho
trovato Non mi interessa Voglio dormire
Ciao ciao Ehi ma aspetta un momento che
cos'è questo
Sì sì Dormi pure Dormi pure non ti
preoccupare Puoi dormire che cosa cos'è
quello cosa hai visto No non ho visto
proprio niente niente niente Vabbè
buonanotte ciao
buonanotte
Eh che stai facendo Io niente non sto
facendo niente l'
trovato trovato No l'ho trovato io l'ho
trovato io ero un er l'ho trovato tu
stavi dormendo l'ho trovato prima io tu
stavi dormendo È stata una mia idea
dicare qua è
via È vio Ora lo apro io no è mio ho
detto è mio devo aprirlo subito così
dient io Io no l'ho trovato
io la sto aprendo prima io eh vabbè Ria
apriamolo assieme di tutti e due Sì è di
tutti e due ma ma che cos'è
Ma quindi era questo il significato del
regalo d'oro Sì siamo noi il regalo
l'Anita Stories Family che belloo io
Circe merlone Merlino e
vitale quindi il significato del regalo
d'oro era questo condividere le cose
perché ora è nostro anche se abbiamo un
po' litigato per prenderlo Ma è
bellissimo questo regalo più bello di
qualsiasi altro perché siamo noi e anche
voi perché anche voi fate parte
dell'anita St Eccoli qua tutti i miei
regali cibo finto cioè cibo però finto
non ci posso ancora credere Guarda
questo è il più bello di tutti secondo
me ed ecco qua invece i miei regali
assieme a questo il cerchietto Lo adoro
ma la cosa più importante sai qual è
questa il regalo d'oro cioè noi questa
rappresenta noi ma anche voi l'Anita
Stories Family Grazie per seguirci ogni
giorno guardare i nostri video lasciare
mi piace è stato super divertente questa
Challenge primo quadro della nostra
Challenge di Roblox dobbiamo superare
questi ostacoli questo primo quadro del
parkour per ora è molto semplice bisogna
evitare gli ostacoli ma è quitale che è
già morto Ecco Vitale che ricomincia
devi evitarli gli ostacoli non devi
andarci con contro
effettivamente
salta
avanti Sì ce l'hai
fatta
Oh no questo è super difficile bisogna
andare piano
piano Speriamo che cada Speriamo che
cada Sì ce l'ha fatta Vitale dal uno
quadro Devo raggiunger Eccomi tocca a me
superare questo quadro devo sbrigarmi
perché Vitale è già più avanti e
ovviamente vincerà che finisce prima il
parkour e prende il bedge finale per
primo quindi sbrighiamoci Ehi un piccolo
ostacolo Io in realtà ho un trucchetto
perché ho le calze con questi gommini
sotto quindi scivolo meno forse e ma è
facilissimo qua mi basta camminare ed
evitare tutti gli ostacoli saltiamo il
primo ostacolo e poi
qua
Ehi aspetta un
momento tu non sei passato qua vero ho
preso la scorciatoia sono passato di qua
tu sei passato solo
qua ce l'ho fatta devo completare questo
quadro che inizia di qua e finisce
laggiù adesso devo sbrigarmi Anita sta
arrivando
corro
sembra un conone di
gelato Ma quindi non è un cono di gelato
Eccomi Vitale Ti sto
raggiungendo ma che sta facendo Vitale
ma forse il cono è solo questo giallo
proviamo a
prenderlo sempre il solito che si deve
sfracellare 10.000 volte Beh meglio così
Approfittiamone e superi
amolo permesso permesso per permesso eh
eh Ehi ma da qua come faccio a salire là
sopra Ah sicuramente devo evitare quello
perché Vitale non è tornato in vita
ancora
Ehi non toccare questo non sono gelati
Ma va si vede benissimo che non sono
gelati Quante volte ti sei sfracellato
già 3 4 2 Secondo voi chi vincerà questa
Challenge io o Vitale ma soprattutto
Quante volte si sfac Vitale scrivetelo
nei commenti e ora meglio che supero
Vitale
Aspetta forse questa la via no ma
bisogna salire là sopra come si fa a
salire là sopra vi qua vado
No dove stai
andando ma che stai facendo attento Ho
sbagliato strada non è
questa è vero non è questa penso perché
qua c'è uno scivolo Quindi bisogna
salire su anche se lì c'è una
scorciatoia è un po' un labirinto questo
Ehi ma qua è tutto chiuso dove dobbiamo
andare devo sbrigarmi
vado non mi
scappi attento Non toccare le pareti
altrimenti muori quali pareti qua sopra
devi stare attento Non toccare qua Ok ok
Devo cercare di spostarmi qua senza
toccare
niente Ce l'ho fatta Vediamo se Vitale
ce la farà Sì sì ho
capito
Ehi aspetta un momento eh Che cos'è
quello Oh non l'avevo visto Tanto tu non
ci passi da lì come non ci passo stavo
facendo il delfino spiaggiato qui evviva
Io prendo la
scorciatoia Ti avevo detto di non
toccare lì come sempre Vitale non mi
ascol è meglio che non tocco questi
ostacoli Comunque come sempre Vitale non
mi ascolta lì c'è una scorciatoia ma è
impossibile passare perché è troppo
stretto e non bisogna toccare le altre
parti quindi forse è meglio continuare
di qua ma non lo dico a Vitale lui
continuerà a provare a salirlo sopra che
cosa non devi dire a Vitale niente
niente Vai pure Vai sali pure là
sopra nel mentre che Vitale continua a
sprell Io passo qua davanti cercando di
superare questi ostacoli sperando che
sia la strada giusta e non che la strada
giusta sia quella di sopra ma lo
scopriremo molto presto che cosa questa
è la strada giusta Sì certo che no
quella in cui stai andando
tua è morta di Nuo ma che sta facendo
Sta strisciando verso qua e beh sì per
non toccare la parte di sopra Ah ha
deciso di seguirmi
Ehi Vai piano e va Ma che stai facendo
quello è un ostacolo È aumentata la
difficoltà Aspetta ce la faccio ce la
faccio povero Vitale mi fa un po' pena
Quante volte si sta
sfracellato Beh almeno sono in vantaggio
questa volta ce la faccio ce la
faccio meno male hai tante vite come i
gatti anche se dovrei essere io un gatto
in questo caso comunque è super
divertente questa Challenge di Roblox
nella vita reale vero Super divertente
Sì sì mi sono sfracellato mille volte
già proprio come nel videogioco Guardate
cosa c'è
qua davanti va davanti io V davanti io
no Vitale mi ha superato Vitale mi ha
superato Devo inventarmi subito qualcosa
Ehi Vitale ho trovato una cosa
bellissima hai presente i coni gelato
che cercavi prima sì guarda c'è un cono
gelato gigante qua uno al cioccolato e
uno al vaniglia No non ci casco come non
ci Cas Dai vieni subito no non ci credo
che è riuscito a passare là in mezzo
come hai fatto Mi sono messo di traverso
ora ci provo io m sto
arrivando eh hai
toccato
Uffa ok di
lato ce l'hai
fatta eh ma dove dobbiamo andare adesso
non lo so Io sto provando da questa
parte un po' a caso ma come caso io
stavo seguendo te Pensavo che sapessi la
e tu non mi devi mai inseguire sai come
sono le cose io non le so quali sono
Vabbè che sta facendo Vitale credi
davvero di riuscire a passare là in
mezzo Tu credi davvero di riuscire a
passare ce l'ho fatta no sei morto
perché hai toccato gli Eh ma che stai
facendo
fermo ma che stai facendo
Vitale non riesce più a alzarsi in piedi
aspetta Ma dove siamo Ma non è questa la
parte giusta no ti sei accorto adesso
che sei tornato dov'eri prima bene
Questa è l'occasione giusta perché
mentre Vitale è incastrato là dentro io
posso tornare di là all'entrata e
provare a salire da sopra nella parte
che abbiamo visto prima Ciao ciao Vitale
forse vincerò io no no vincerò io ci
provo da qui e che stai facendo
No no che sta facendo ti si vedono le
mande è un po' difficile perché scivolo
Ah è uno scivolo Questo ecco perché
guarda che non riesce a salire daa sopra
Infatti si scivola ti conviene tornare
indietro Dai Secondo me puoi farcela
Provaci ancora no si scivola Ecco Vitale
che prova a salire nello scivolo ma ha
le calze troppo
scivolose
Oh Ah Dai riprova puoi
farcela riprovaci varie volte così
rimarrai lì per un bel po' di tempo Io
nel frattempo provo a salire da qua Oh
là c'è un altro
passaggio proviamo Italia sta
continuando a provare a salire dallo
scivolo Ma non penso che ci riuscirà mai
mi
vedete non penso di riuscirci a salire
qua sopra ma ci provo ma che sta facendo
Vitale sta provando a salire da lì eh
Guarda che non si può salire da lì Ma
che fai è scomparso ok Devo cercare di
non toccare
niente forse ci sono riuscita Ora la
parte più difficile Sono le
gambe posso toccare la parte gialla ma
non posso toccare la parte verde di
sotto il problema è che non posso
toccare neanche questa sta
parte ho avuto un'idea migliore vi
ricordate che vi ho detto che io ho le
calze con i gommini sotto antiscivolo
potrei riuscire a salire dallo scivolo
invece che passare qua che è
difficilissimo andiamo ok Eccomi tornata
qua Devo solo superare questi ostacoli
adesso ma dov'è finito Vitale non c'è
più non mi dire che è uscito dal
gioco Forse si era stancato perché si è
sfracellato così tante volte che ha
deciso di uscire dal gioco Che strano
Vabbè noi continuiamo via superiamo
questo
Staco e anche questo Ehi Ma come ha
fatto prima Vitale a passare qua Forse
devo per forza buttarmi Ok Eccomi devo
buttarmi a Quasi quasi faccio un
riposino qua Ah no devo trovare Vitale e
anche finire l'escape Room e prendere il
bge prima di Vitale proviamo a salire
dallo scivolo con le mie calze
antiscivolo Ehi ho le calze antiscivolo
con i gomini e anche le orecchie da
gatto proprio come un vero gatto Ok
andiamo Ecco qua lo scivolo Oh no la mia
calza scivola lo stesso ma insomma le
calze antis scivolo dovrebbero non farmi
scivolare ma scivolano lo stesso Uffa in
questo caso sarebbe stato utile vitale
per aiutarmi mi avrebbe potuto dare una
mano e trascinarmi sopra
riproviamo
Devo provare a salire
velocissimamente posso
farcela è inutile non ce la faccio dove
starà finito Vitale perché ha lasciato
il gioco proprio adesso ho bisogno del
suo
aiuto puffa Non ce la farò mai Ehi ma tu
sei qua Vitale Aspetta ti do una mano sì
dai ti do una mano eri qua tutto il
tempo E certo Dai ti tiro su io Ok
grazie Dai ce la fai Ce la fai ci sono
quasi Ehi aspetta un momento ma tu prima
mi hai fatto sfracellare migliaia di
volte
[Musica]
no te ne pentirai mi vendicherò Rita Ti
ho fregata io continuo l'escape
Ciao muffa mi hai
imbrogliata Vediamo se riesce a evitare
tutti gli
ostacoli sta diventando più
bravo un altro
ostacolo Ma come sta
camminando dov'è andato dentro al
tubo Uffa Vitale sta continuando a
andare avanti io non riesco a salire in
questo scivolo sembra così piccolo
questo scivolo sembra così facile
salirci ma è difficilissimo Come avrà
fatto Vitale Beh mi resta solo una cosa
tornare indietro e riprovare a salire da
là ok posso toccare il giallo ma non il
verde Dev stare attenta qua sopra mi
devo spostare
qua
Ok Qua non devo toccare
Ehi ma come faccio a salire qua sopra se
è
verde devo per forza appoggiarmi qua
Ah per fortuna in questa posso
appoggiarmi
ce l'ho fatta qua è dov'era Vitale prima
lo riconosc vedete vedete quello è lo
scivolo evitale prima il passato da
Eccolo sta arrivando Che cosa vuole fare
aiuto perché sta arrivando
qua ennesimo sfocamento di Vitale io
devo sbrigarmi Magari passo di là
andiamo Spero che non venga qua stai Ehi
Lasciami in pace mi hai imbrogliata
prima nello scivolo Quindi ora non SC
imbrogliato
prima scappiamo da Vitale altrimenti mi
butterà negli ostacoli Sto
arrivando fermo lì
Ehi ma che fai Ti
gli prendi questi ostacoli Eh ma dove
stai
scappando
Aspetta un momento sì non c'è una via
d'uscita qua e Effettivamente era un po'
che giravo intorno qui Se passo di qua
torno dov'ero prima ma qual è la via
d'uscita Allora non lo so ma
Ehi credo sia quella l'uscita c'è anche
il bge è vero Dobbiamo trovare il modo
di andare laggiù Eh sì ma allora
dobbiamo tornare al piano di sotto m
credo proprio di sì E io credo di essere
avvantaggiato perché da qui è più facile
Ciao Ferma No Da dove passo passo da qua
Ehi Che stai facendo Mi stai in
tranciando la St te Sei tu che mi stai
tracciando passa dall'altra no mi metto
qui dovrei passare su di me sembri un
bruco dentro una mela verde ma vorrò
dire che mi trasformerò in una
bellissima farfalla
Addio fermo fermo passo da questa parte
allora in questo Tubo
giallo Lui è già Laggiù ha superato
tutti gli
ostacoli oh oh oh
oh Ben ti sta così impari a correre Io
meglio che vado piano così evito di
sfracellarsi questo è un aiutante sembra
proprio un personaggio di
Roblox credevi mi fossi arreso eh e
invece no vado
avanti fermo torna
qua qua serviranno le mie cal anti
scivolo devo andare a prendere devo
raggiungere
Vitale non devo toccare le reti e non
devo
cadere per fortuna queste
calze ce l'ho fatta dov'è andato Ah
nello scipolo Ciao ciao
perdente Sto arrivando Ehi fermo lì ora
ti raggiungo subito no no Aiuto Aiuto
[Musica]
dov'è andato Sto arrivando Io sono in
vantaggio
Ahia Ma insomma fammi andar via Ahia
ahia metti una pallina verde tu via
scappi Ahia aiuto fermo fermo
fermo si è spiaccicato in questo
ostacolo ea
Eh aspetta C'è
l'uscita l'uscita era
qua e non ce ne siamo accorti Noi siamo
saliti lì sin là sopra ma l'uscita era
qua a fianco come mai non te ner Ria
accorto
Eh vabbè Vitale sta cercando di evitare
l'ostacolo Ah eraa qui l'uscita via Ehi
aspetta fermo fermo
Ciao
ferma no Vitale mi sta superando devo
correre sta arrivando al
bge
Ferma
eh non riesce non riesce a camminare
Ehi sto prendendo il
Peo Vitale è caduto due volte Ora che
lui è a terra posso approfittarne e
prendere il veggio prima di lui andiamo
Spero di non cadere anch'io Ah me lo
impedirò fermo non lo prend fermo non lo
prenderei
fermo Ci sono quasi
no
Fermati Sì l'ho
preso basta Ho vinto Ho già
vinto dai Siccome ho vinto Ti aiuto ad
alzarti ci vuole una gru prendo anche io
il bedge anche se l'hai preso prima tu
eh c'ho il bge anch'io Escape Room
superata 3 2 1 via Vieni vieni vieni
vieni vieni qua
salta ben Benvenuti in salita Stories
oggi video speciale costruiremo un parco
giochi in giardino per il nostro cane
Merlino in più sarà un parco giochi
speciale perché sarà un percorso con
vari ostacoli e varie cose super
divertenti e poi faremo una gara perché
faremo il percorso assieme a Merlino sia
io che Vitale vedremo alla fine se ho
vinto io o se ha vinto Vitale poi
potrete scriverci nei commenti Qual è
stato Secondo voi il momento più
divertente di questa Challenge e volete
vedere altre challeng con Merlino in cui
facciamo qualcosa con Merlino Costruiamo
qualcosa lasciate un bel mi piace Anzi
consigliateci pure tutte le vostre idee
giù nei commenti Mettetevi comodi
prendete i Popcorn e iniziamo a
costruire il percorso
[Musica]
fuori
[Applauso]
[Musica]
Merlino tra poco dovrai giocare nel tuo
parco giochi e fare il percorso sei
pronto sei contento Merlino sta finendo
di montare le ultime cose per il parco
giochi 3 2 1
[Musica]
[Applauso]
via
Merlino Merlino è andato subito al tubo
Merlino e chi c'è qua chi c'è qua
Merlino entra dentro entra
[Risate]
dentro
curiosone qua dentro Merlino chi c'è qua
dentro no Merlino non si entra
lì entra da qui ma che
fai Merlino
Bra
bravo Ti piace il giun ma ma che stai
facendo
Merlino No non si ruba Quello è il
solito ladro ora vi Guido nel parco
giochi e percorso che abbiamo preparato
per Merlino Innanzitutto Qua ci sono dei
pali per fare lo slalon quindi Merlino
dovrà fare lo slalom tutto qua fino a
qua e poi qua e poi girerà qua qua
dietro dietro questo albero e poi dovrà
correre e saltare fino a dentro al
cerchio hai visto
Merlino poi dopo aver saltato nel
cerchio dovrà entrare dentro al tubo e
uscire dal
tubo Ciao Merlino Ciao Secondo voi
riuscirà Merlino a completare tutto il
percorso Se riuscirà a completare tutto
il percorso lo aspetterà un premio
Vediamo se riuscirà a Grazie per si fa
giri per l'evento si è aggiunto anche il
pubblico che sta osservando se Merlino
ce la farà a superare tutto il
[Applauso]
percorso inizia il percorso Vitale con
Merlino e poi toccherà a me
vediamo inizi uno
slalon attenzione ha un po' saltato
qualche palo Merlino ha saltato qualche
palo Vediamo se riesce a fare il
giro sta ricominciando il percorso da
capo Vediamo se ce la fa questa volta di
qua Bravo ecco qua che Merlino fa lo
slalon bravissimo bravo di qua
bravissimo Vediamo se riesci a fare il
salto adesso
[Musica]
seduto salto Il Salto Salto
salta dai dai dai salta
dai
no Merlino ha schivato il
cerchio dai Merlino puoi ancora F dentro
Merlino Merlino dentro dentro prendo
dentro vediamo Se entrerà nel
tubo
Bravo
[Applauso]
bravo Merino e vitale hanno fatto lo
slalom e il tubo quindi hanno fatto 100
punti Bravo Merlino Bravo tocca a me con
Merlino vediamo se riesco a fare più
punti di Vitale andiamo Merlino Merlino
è
perplesso pronti Daci via e 1 e 2 e 3
via vieni Merlino vieni Merlino vieni
Merlino corri corri corri corri corri
corri corri corri corri corri nien qua
ni Merlino è più confuso di prima vi
vieni qua Bra
bravo ora vediamo se riusciamo a fare il
salto sei pronto Merlino dai corri corri
corri corri Guarda guarda
no qua Merlino qua che devi saltare
Merlino Vieni vieni corri dai Merlino
salta
no tunnel tunnel vai nel tunnel Merlino
Merlino tunnel Vai Merlino guarda
Guarda No Merlino no sta facendo il T al
contrario no Merlino entra dentro il
turn Dai
vieni vieni
Merlino Merlino vuole fare il tunnel al
contrario Ma perché fai il tunnel Al
contrario io e Merlino Purtroppo abbiamo
fat solo 50 punti perché abbiamo fatto
solo lo slalom e non ha fatto il salto
nel tunnel quindi non sono stata una
brava trainer invece Vitalia ha fatto
100 punti ma questa era solo la corsa di
prova ora facciamo quella ufficiale a
tempo siete pronti
bravo zampa
[Musica]
Bravo l'ha fatto al
contrario
Z bravo che
[Musica]
carino
bravo che bravo qualcuno qui è molto
perplesso sulle reale capacità di
Merlino Infatti sta schiacciando un
pisolino come potete vedere Ciao
micione Ciao pronti per il primo round
ufficiale a inizio il Oh no Merlino sta
scappando vieni Merlino è qua tre 3 2 1
via Vieni vieni vieni vieni vien
qua vieni qua vi
Ahia Bravo corri corri corri vieni Vieni
marlino sì dai sbrigati
sì vai vai salta salta
Bra tunnel tunnel tunnel tunnel Marino
bravissimo Bravo brati Tutti e tre Sì il
turno di Vitale siete pronti 3 2 1
via di qua di qua di qua di quaa di qua
bravo bravo bravo bravo Merlino Bravo
Bravo bravo bravissimo Merlino
bravissimo Vai vai pr pr e vi qua vieni
vieni vieni vieni
vieni no Merlino ha schivato il
salto Merino Vieni vieni vieni dai Dai
vieni vieni vieni vieni dai zampa zampa
zampa zampa zampa Dai bravissimo Bra e
ora il tunnel Merlino Merlino Prendilo
prendilo bravo Ma che
bravo è stato bravissimo tieni brav ahia
bravissimo Merlino che ha vinto tutte le
Challenge Merlino è arrivato il momento
delle premi azioni vero Merlino Sì sì
ecco il premio di Merlino Che buono Lo
mangio tutto Allora Merlino ci fai un
ultimo salto eh quale salto io sono
stato bravo vi vieni Vai
Marino Vai Marin zappa zappa
bravissimo
Bravo Merlino rosicchia il suo premio ed
è
felicissimo Merlino lasci ben un
pezzo che
[Musica]
bellino
divertito Merlino con questo porco
Giochi in questa
[Risate]
Challenge ok ragazzi Noi ci siamo
divertiti tantissimo e anche Merlino è
stato troppo divertente questa Challenge
Mi raccomando lasciate un bel mi piace
se volete vedere altre Challenge del
genere costruiremo qualcos'altro per
merlina E ora vi lasciamo Qua quattro
caselline su cui cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video cliccate su quella
che preferite e buona visione cia
[Musica]
ciao